ja ich muss sagen mir wird Angst und
Bange wenn ich mir ansehe was ich in
unserer Wirtschaft zusammen Braut und
das ist ja ein riesiger Tsunami im
Grunde der auf uns zu rollt und wir
haben eine Regierung die tut so als
kennen wir in leichten Wellengang also
Herr habich hat ja vor kurzem so gesagt
ja also wenn das Wetter mitspielt dann
kommen wir auch irgendwie ganz gut über
den Winter na klar wenn der Winter
ausfallen würde wäre sicher noch besser
ich finde wirklich das sage ich jetzt
nicht weil ich Opposition bin sondern
auch bei früheren Regierungen ich hatte
immer viel zu kritisieren es ist wurde
auch sicher manches falsch gemacht aber
ich muss sagen eine Regierung die so
völlig ohne Konzept ohne Plan war in
einer so schwierigen Situation die sogar
immer noch eigene Fehler zusätzlich
macht wo handwerklich eigentlich nichts
stimmt das finde ich erschreckend und
wenn man seriöse Prognosen für die
nächste Zeit sich an sie die Bundesbank
sagt ja wir kriegen eine beispiellose
Inflation zweistelliger Bereich und
gleichzeitig wird die Wirtschaft
einbrechen und wir haben jetzt ja die
ersten Vorboten die Holger Preise also
das ist das was die Industrie bezahlt
sind um 45 Prozent gestiegen sowas hat
Deutschland noch nicht erlebt also das
gab es vielleicht früher in Italien mit
der Lira aber das gab es noch nie in
Deutschland und das heißt ja es wird ein
wahnsinniger eine wahnsinnige
kostenwelle und wenn ich mit Leuten aus
der Wirtschaft spreche ob das Handwerker
sind Bäcker sind oder eben auch Leute
mit kleinen Unternehmen auch mittleren
Unternehmen im industriellen Bereich die
sagen teilweise okay sie merken es noch
nicht weil sie noch langlaufende
Verträge haben aber wenn die Kosten so
bleiben und wenn Sie das voll irgendwann
bezahlen müssen dann höre ich von allen
Seiten das Überleben wir nicht dann sind
wir weg und der industrielle Mittelstand
in Deutschland das ist das Rückgrat
unserer Wirtschaft das ist die Basis
unseres Wohlstands wenn das kaputt geht
dann möchte ich mir die ausmalen wie das
hier in Deutschland aussieht und ich
meine ich bin jemand der immer für
Umverteilung Eintritt auch jetzt
natürlich aber wenn nichts mehr das
Umfeld teilen dann wird es ganz schlecht
und was ich wirklich ein gut finde die
Regierung wäre ja in der Pflicht wenn
sie sagt wir wollen von Russland kein
Gas und kein Öl mehr kaufen dann
bitteschön muss sie einen Plan haben was
ist die Alternative wo bekommen wir
ähnlich preiswertes Öl und gasher klar
wenn jetzt Norwegen und die Niederlande
riesige Gasfelder plötzlich entdecken
und wir könnten von da importieren super
würde ich auch sagen ist viel viel
schöner aber aktuell sieht es so aus wir
haben keine Alternative es gibt keine
und dann finde ich es verantwortungslos
dann nicht billige Energie weiter zu
kaufen zumal wir sehen die Sanktionen
Schaden Russland nicht Russland
Staatskasse ist vollgasprom macht
Rekordgewinne dadurch dass die die
Preise so gestiegen sind also wir
Schaden uns und Olaf Scholz hat im März
den Bürgern und Bürgern versprochen im
Bundestag das ist keine Sanktionen geben
wird die uns mehr Schaden als der
russischen Führung und ich muss sagen
wenn man ihn an dieses Versprechen
erinnert dann müsste er jetzt eigentlich
als Bundeskanzler sofort sagen Stopp wir
brauchen hier nicht weiter es gibt ja
auch Vorschläge von der Regierung wie
zum Beispiel die Verstaatlichung von
manchen gasimporteuren uniper war jetzt
der erste Großbritannien hat jetzt zum
Beispiel das frackingverbot aufgehoben
müsse da Deutschland innovativer werden
naja die Verstaatlichung ist ja eine
Notmaßnahme also ich bin immer jemand
der sagt so wichtige Bereiche wie
Energieversorgung sollten in kommunaler
Hand aber das was wir jetzt machen das
ist ein Milliardengrab also im
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages wurde
ja so geschätzt dass das mehrere hundert
Milliarden verschlingen kann und wir
übernehmen jetzt alle Verluste also man
hat auch den Eigentümer von Juniper
jetzt in einer Weise freigekauft von
Verlusten die ich unverantwortlich finde
mit deutschem Steuergeld also es ist
auch wirklich handwerklich ganz schlecht
gemacht also da oder die gasumlage ist
ja das gleiche beim Fracking muss ich
ehrlich sagen ich verstehe die
Verzweiflung dass man jetzt irgendwie
alternative Energien irgendwo herbekommt
aber Fracking muss man wissen ist eine
hochriskante Technologie da werden
hochgiftige Chemikalien mit Wasser
zusammen in ganz tiefe 1 Schichten
gepresst das kann ganz schnell das
Grundwasser mit berühren es gibt
Untersuchungen in den USA dass in der
Nähe von Fracking mehr Menschen die
Menschen früher sterben als woanders und
wir hatten auch in Deutschland in
Niedersachsen eine bedenkliche Häufung
zum Beispiel von blutkrebsfällen in der
Nähe von frackingorten ich glaube nicht
dass das eine gute Technologie ist die
wir jetzt in Deutschland massenhaft
anwenden sollten also die Lösung ist
noch nicht gefunden von der Regierung
aber Bela wie ist denn findest du in die
Kommunikation der Regierung also neben
den Möglichkeiten den Maßnahmen die
kommuniziert denn die Regierung die
Krise also es ist schwierig solche
Krisen zu kommunizieren das sage ich
vorweg als jemand der ja auch unter
Druck stand und natürlich in schwierigen
Zeiten dann sowas kommuniziert hat wie
die Agenda 2010 wo ich natürlich
erheblich dann auch unter Druck geraten
bin auch aus den eigenen Reihen auch aus
Seiten 3 in der SPD damals nicht also
und wir erleben ja jetzt dass ich
täglich etwas ändert und jemand wie
Robert Habeck das muss man sagen
sich natürlich auch nicht vorstellen
können als ins Amt gekommen ist dass er
einmal Öl
Raffinerien drei an der Zahl in
Deutschland verstaatlicht dass er
Gasunternehmen verstaatlichen wird und
mit Staats gekauft sondern er hat
geträumt von der schönen neuen grünen
Welt und jetzt muss es einen grünen
Abgeordneten Freunden erklären warum ein
guter Geschichtenerzähler das müsst ihr
mir jetzt eigentlich zum Vorteil werden
ist es leider nicht weil er beginnt ja
die Nerven zu verlieren das haben wir im
Bundestag gesehen und auch bei seiner
Pressekonferenz Katastrophe also da ist
wirklich und bei seinem Auftritt bei
Maischberger da ist die Kommunikation
sehr schlecht aber vielleicht noch
Einsatz vorweg gestellt also das ist
eine ganz schwierige Situation von
jemanden der ausgezogen ist die Welt zu
verändern sie grüner zu machen als sie
ich und ist und jetzt jemand der sich
mit der alten Industrie quasi über
diesen und hoffentlich auch über den
nächsten Winter retten muss aber die
Kommunikation ist man kann das nicht
anders sagen gerade aus dem Hause habe
ich leider die war gut die war sehr
detailliert ich war einmal überrascht
wenn ich diese Papiere gesehen habe da
die Presseerklärung wie detailliert in
den letzten ein zwei Wochen kommt da
eine wahrigkeit rein eine
unvorbereitetheit eine handwerkliche ja
man kann es nicht anders sagen stimmt
bereit die schon atemlos macht und wir
haben das gesehen bei dem Auftritt von
Robert Habeck bei Maischberger war es
sorry dass ich die konkurrenzauftritt
wurde deshalb eine Insolvenz ist es
natürlich nicht wenn ich kein Geld mehr
habe bin ich irgendwann Pleite dann muss
ich Insolvenz anmelden sonst betreibe
ich insolvenzverschleppungen das war
genau der Stich auch in die richtige
Richtung die man ihm davor geworfen hat
des zweite haben wir ja jetzt gesehen
gasumlage wieder sonst doch später
zugekommen aber gasumlage wird uns
tagelang erklärt und auch suggeriert na
wenn Juniper verstartet wird dieser
große Energiekonzern was richtig ist wie
ich finde dann brauchen wir die
gasumlage nicht diesen Eindruck gibt
Robert Habeck bei seiner Pressekonferenz
was kann man das beim Mittwoch auf jeden
Fall also gestern glaube ich um 8:30 Uhr
morgens auch noch selber wieder
gegenüber von Journalisten die auch
nicht nachfragen in dieser Richtung sagt
ja also gasumlage naja da gucken wir
noch mal vielleicht brauchen wir das
nicht also dem Sinn nach wenig später
muss er aber klären die gasumlage kommt
doch der Opposition AFD aber immerhin
hat die richtige Frage gestellt wie ist
das denn mit ihrer gasumlage brüllt er
dann an mit einer stimm die die drüber
gelegt wirkt also verliert völlig die
Fassung und geht gar nicht auf das
Argument ein er ist glaube ich nicht
gewohnt so unter Druck zu stehen er ist
jemand der natürlich eine harte Zeit
hatte das muss man ihm zugestehen er hat
viel auf den Weg gebracht vieles von dem
ich glaube das ist das Urproblem was er
nicht will und wollte was seine Partei
auch nicht will und muss das jetzt
irgendwie mit sich und seiner Partei
klar kriegen und das ist einfach ist
mein Eindruck ein bisschen viel
mitgehen bei der These dass die
Regierung die Wirtschaft zerstört
das kann ich nicht einschätzen aber was
ich von der krumme Krisenkommunikation
sehe dann ist das eigentlich die
Fortführung dessen was man auch einen
anderen Bereichen sehen das ist
erratisch es ist der nimmt die Menschen
nicht mit die Überraschung die rein sich
wie auf dem Faden und nicht nur
diejenigen für die für die
Oppositionsparteien sondern auch für den
für den Bürger und da noch dann dran zu
bleiben und mitzugehen ist sicherlich
schwer aber was man braucht ist
sicherlich auch eine strategische weit
nach vorne schauen den Blick und den
sehe ich nicht man muss irgendwo auch
den Leuten sagen pass mal auf jetzt das
ist das was wir haben als Problem und wo
wurden wir in einem Jahr wo werden in
zwei Jahren was wissen wir was wissen
wir nicht und was glauben wir was
Richtiges zu tun und das vermisse ich
herr Frank spüren Sie die Existenzängste
auch schon in ihrer Arztpraxis
also ich würde schon sagen dass sie
viele bei einer Patienten Gedanken
machen ich würde sagen sonst in zwei
Richtungen das eine ist das unmittelbare
also das sind einfach Existenzängste
ganz klar und das sind halt auch
Menschen die die wohnen in der
Dreizimmerwohnung haben zwei Kinder und
ich glaube viele die jetzt öffentlich
das diskutieren können sich nicht
vorstellen was da passiert also man auch
kleine Handwerker und dergleichen das
kann ich in der Öffentlichkeit leicht
über Moral reden wenn ich dann halt
einfach meinen mein Schwimmbad weniger
heizen muss oder mein Gästezimmer was
macht das denn mit der Gesundheit wenn
wir beispielsweise auf diese 19 Grad
gehen hier überall gefordert werden
wahrscheinlich werden es dann noch 18
also ich glaube ich ich sehe jetzt
weniger die Gefahr dass die Leute sich
dann erkälten und dann Corona kriegen
aber nein es ist diese Angst schädigt
die Gesundheit des insgesamt sind die
Leute auch Corona und unter Angst
gesetzt worden jetzt kommt diese Angst
dazu und die halte ich auch für Real ja
die sind dieser Abstieg dieser soziale
dass jetzt die Leute enorm unter Stress
und dann gibt es aber auch eine Art von
von Problemen oder von Stress was ich
schon lange Jahre sehe das
führt ein bisschen mehr in die Tiefe
ich habe wirklich auch viele viele
Fachleute bei mir in der Praxis die ist
direkt neben der Universitäten
Heidelberg und ich habe immer wieder
tolle Leute die aber sagen sie kommen
mit ihrem Fachwissen nicht mehr durch in
den Gremien ja es wird immer mehr
moralisiert seit 20 Jahren kann man mit
mit tollen moralischen Thesen Karriere
machen wenn man aber beweisen muss dass
das auch Substanz hat und Zahlen und
Fakten liefert braucht man das nicht und
Kompetenz wird als Bedrohung empfunden
und dann werden
sozialgerichtet und ausgegrenzt man kann
es ja so hart sagen so finde ich es ist
glaube ich den Eindruck dass ich
regelrechte Inkompetenz Netzwerke
verbreitet haben bis in die Kommunen
hinein und daran verzweifeln auch viele
und ich glaube dass das summiert das
kommt jetzt alles irgendwie so zusammen
die Leute können einfach nicht mehr
sehen dass die politischen
Entscheidungen auf irgendeinem
Sachverstand eine Debatte um die guten
Argumente beruht sondern der wird
wirklich aktionistisch agiert
dilettantisch und das auch mit einer
Moral verbremt und das macht auch sehr
vielen Sorgen ja Inkompetenz ist dann
natürlich auch infektiös wir haben
trotzdem einen Sektor die Regierung
versagt dann traut man ja auch auf
anderen Sektoren nicht mehr das Weg ist
vielleicht die eigentliche solche die
führende immunologische infektiös da
muss man aufpassen
schon alles was man immer aufpassen was
die Wissenschaftler sagen das ist
richtig aber ich habe Corona gelehrt
immer auf die Wissenschaftler hören da
kommt man gut weiter das würde ich aber
anders sehen das wollte ich damit machen